[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos en France 24
Bienvenidos a una entrevista con el
presidente de la república de Argentina
Alberto Fernández señor presidente mucho
gusto un gusto Gracias por invitarme
quiero empezar con Venezuela hubo acá en
París un encuentro entre el presente de
Francia de Colombia y usted con
representante de la oposición y del
gobierno de Nicolás maduro Hay una
posibilidad verdadera que hay una
reanudación del diálogo entre los dos
Campos yo Definitivamente creo que sí
hace ya varios años se estableció algo
que se llamó al grupo de contactos que
le dieron Noruega y del que México y
Argentina éramos partes donde
básicamente lo que planteamos era que
los venezolanos se sienten a resolver
sus diferencias
eso fue muy difícil de hacer porque en
los años de Donald Trump Donald Trump
hizo todo lo necesario por dividir a
Venezuela por dejar en una situación de
aislamiento
Venezuela el presidente macrón nos
convocó y creo que hemos dado un paso
muy importante para que vuelva a
reanudarse el diálogo entre
una parte de la oposición que sigue
resistiendo a dialogar con el presidente
maduro y el gobierno del presidente
maduro digo una parte de la oposición
porque Venezuela tiene un sistema
electoral que
Se va se va desarrollando en etapa
primero se eligen alcaldes después
eligen gobernadores de Estados y
finalmente se elige el presidente y
elecciones de alcaldes y de gobernadores
ya se han hecho en procesos electorales
donde participó la oposición y fueron
absolutamente incuestionables y hay
datos muy relevantes para demostrar la
transparencia de esos comicios por
ejemplo el estado más numeroso en
habitantes y en votantes que se llama
zulia fue ganado por la oposición el
estado donde nació Chávez fue ganado por
la oposición eso demuestra que el
proceso electoral se está desarrollando
con total transparencia y sin
cuestionamientos aún así queda una parte
de la oposición que sigue cuestionando
al gobierno del presidente maduro y lo
que nosotros buscamos es que reanudan el
diálogo encuentren un mecanismo para
convivir democráticamente y para
facilitar
el desarrollo de Venezuela porque
Venezuela está sufriendo sanciones
económicas realmente difíciles usted
habló de este tema de sanciones con la
Casa Blanca en Washington qué dicen creo
que usted conversó con Jake Sullivan el
Consejo de Seguridad sobre este tema lo
he hablado muchas veces y yo creo que
están cambiando las sanciones económicas
que aplicó Trump fueron realmente
brutales sobre sobre Venezuela
Y la verdad la acción que desplegó de
aislamiento de Venezuela bueno dejó los
efectos que todos Vimos una Venezuela
empobrecida donde emigraron millones de
venezolanos Ahora yo creo que el
gobierno del presidente vaiden tiene una
mirada más razonable sobre el conflicto
y yo creo que podemos ir camino a que
ellos también se incorporen a ayudar a
una solución definitiva aliviando las
sanciones por ejemplo claro también la
Unión Europea tiene que
trabajar en ese sentido porque el mismo
día que nos reuníamos con macron y con
Petro
ese mismo día la Unión Europea volvía a
renovar las sanciones sobre Venezuela
eso hay que terminarlo porque eso hay
que terminar con la el reconocimiento de
Juan guaidó bueno Juan guaidó es una
cosa insólita que se iba haciendo
reconocido como presidente de Venezuela
porque no tiene ninguna legitimidad
absolutamente ninguna legitimidad Europa
está al final tienen que cambiar pero
definitivamente porque eso fue todo eso
el mundo cayó en la trampa de Donald
Trump Esta es la verdad que construyó un
presidente
elegido de un modo muy singular en una
plaza con un grupo de diputados que
decidió hacerlo presidente de Venezuela
Entonces
yo creo que con eso hay que terminar
creo que hay que reconocer a las
autoridades venezolanas y que hay que
garantizar dos cosas
la Argentina acompañó siempre al alto
comisionado de Derechos Humanos en
Naciones Unidas se habla de crímenes muy
graves en las denuncias más severas que
hizo contra Venezuela Argentina acompañó
eso o sea nosotros no necesitamos
avalando
nos vamos avalando y al mismo tiempo
queriendo hacer custodios de que esas
cosas no ocurran más en Venezuela ha
habido muchos progresos porque el alto
comisionado se instaló en Caracas y pudo
haber de cerca la evolución del tema en
materia de Derechos Humanos del mismo
modo queremos ser garantes y queremos
ser custodios de que el proceso
electoral sigue haciendo tan
transparente como ha sido hasta ahora y
yo lo que veo es en el gobierno del
presidente maduro la vocación de hacerlo
y mientras esto ocurra creo que el
diálogo bienvenido Bienvenido sea quiero
hablar de otra situación la que preocupa
mucha gente en Europa la quiera en
Ucrania Usted dijo al Foro de la paz
tenemos el imperativo ético de no
quedarnos callados y el imperativo ético
de ser claros hace unos meses Lula dijo
que el presidente de Ucrania voló
delanski era tan responsable como
Vladimir Putin de la guerra es su
opinión también
Las Guerras son como el tango se bailan
de a dos y necesitan de dos pero la
responsabilidad no son las mismas
claramente o alguien que invadió el
territorio del otro y ese es el que
inicia el problema y el otro En todo
caso claro y el otro En todo caso se
defenderá lo que sí está claro que a
esta altura de los acontecimientos son
los dos los que tienen que encontrar una
solución el presidente de Ucrania y el
presidente de Rusia pero no quieren y
absolutamente hay que encontrar una
solución la guerra no es la solución
siempre donde aparece la guerra la
verdad sale corriendo entonces la guerra
no puede ser solución en un mundo que ha
padecido millones de muertes por una
pandemia Y que ahora aparece muertes por
razón de una disputa territorial
era una educación y de una invasión como
la que hizo Rusia a Ucrania Por eso digo
la guerra hoy necesita de dos pero la
verdad es que alguien la empezó el que
la empezó fue Rusia que no debió haber
invadido territorio ucraniano que se
puede hacer ahí la Cumbre del en unos
días usted se va a Bali Yo vengo
hablando con macrón desde hace ya mucho
tiempo y gracias a Dios hemos logrado un
muy buen diálogo y un muy buen
entendimiento con el presidente macrón
lo primero que quiero que el mundo
entienda Es que la guerra que transcurre
en el hemisferio norte es padecida por
el hemisferio sur Entonces por lo tanto
queremos que yo quiero que el hemisferio
sur sea oída en la búsqueda de la Paz No
hay nada más Revolucionario que reclamar
la paz en el mundo del presente en el
mundo que vivimos no podemos vivir en
guerras es una guerra además muy cruenta
porque Más allá de los disparos y de las
muertes y de los ejércitos que se
enfrentan hay un continente que está
apareciendo se llama Europa que parece
falta de energía
que parece problemas también de
suministro de alimentos
y hay un hay un hay un hemisferio que es
el hemisferio sur donde el afao está pre
anunciando una hambruna que va a afectar
a 300 millones de habitantes casi todos
del hemisferio sur Entonces nosotros nos
podemos ser complacientes con esa
realidad y por eso estoy planteando que
nos sentemos para exigirle a las partes
en disputa que se sienten a buscar una
salida
dialogada que vuelve que ese es el fuego
que se sienten encontrar una salida y
que terminen con esta guerra que está
afectando a muchos mucho más que Europa
mucho más que Europa y que todas las
partes que están involucradas Estados
Unidos Europa la otan Rusia Ucrania
bueno se sienten y Encuentran una
solución
al g20 habrá también el Primer Ministro
de Gran Bretaña richizumak Obviamente el
Reino Unido dijo que iba a negociar con
Mau la devolución de la arquiteliago de
chagos pero con las malvinas No pasa
nada en la última reunión del g7 tuve
una reunión bilateral con Boris Johnson
que en ese momento era el Primer
Ministro se cambian parece que pasó
mucho tiempo no y
[Música]
lo que le dije es Podemos hablar lo que
quieras sobre la relación Argentina
británica Pero lo primero que hay que
hablar es el tema de malvinas para
nosotros eso sigue siendo
una cuestión pero no hay movimiento
bueno porque
no quieren el Reino Unido se niega a
cumplir la resolución de Naciones Unidas
que lo obliga a sentarse en una mesa de
negociación
para resolver el problema de la
soberanía argentina se niega eso y ha
convertido a esas dos Islas
en una base militar en el Atlántico Sur
que como todo como todo América del Sur
es una zona de paz es una persona sin
militarización
Yo espero que en algún momento el Reino
Unido recapacite y renueve su vocación
de diálogo o la hagan hacer No sé
renovarla no la van a hacer que nazca su
vocación de dialogar y que de ese modo
podamos sentarnos a discutirlos
verdaderamente nos importa que es
recuperar la soberanía territorial
Argentina al g20 también Creo que habrá
una reunión con la titular del fondo
monetario internacional cristalinato
lleva
tal vez para revisar el acuerdo de marzo
O tal vez para reclamar que el fmi
elimine los sobrecargos no que cobran a
los países endeudados como Argentina
Usted sabe que la Argentina fue
endeudada por el gobierno que me
precedió de un modo muy responsable y el
fondo monetario internacional fue muy
irresponsable por el modo en que prestó
ese dinero tuvo un solo objetivo que fue
un objetivo político que era beneficiar
al gobierno saliente Pero la realidad es
que dejando esto de lado le dejó a la
Argentina una deuda que varias
generaciones
van a tener que pagar
como Argentina como el monto fue tan
alto Argentina accedió a un crédito que
hice mucho más de lo que puede recibir
Entonces por ese exceso de créditos paga
un interés especial que significa
triplicar la tasa de interés que el
banco que el fondo monetario cobra para
nosotros eso es algo insostenible y
venimos planteando ya desde el g20 de
Roma Ya hace mucho tiempo
de alguna manera también se solventa con
esos sobrecargos pero lo que pasa es que
ahora ha pasado la pandemia
pasa la guerra la guerra este año
2022 a la Argentina le costó
5 mil millones de dólares esta guerra
que es plata que tuvimos que usar dinero
que tuvimos que usar para pagar energía
más cara alimentados más caros y
fertilizantes más caros y nosotros lo
que necesitamos ahora es que el fondo
monetario entienda que después de la
pandemia y después de la guerra estas
cosas deben ser revisadas una de las
víctimas de los sobrecargos se llamó
Ucrania
que también está sobre endeudada
no se trata de que no queremos pagar los
intereses que correspondan lo que no
queremos es ser tratados con una suerte
de intereses punitorios que son
Realmente desmedidos y que dice el creen
Bueno al final va a cambiar o yo creo
que tiene vocación de hacerlo pero es
una decisión que tiene tomar el borde
del fondo monetario y ahí es donde viene
la disputa y viene la parte más difícil
el acuerdo de libre comercio entre el
mercosur y la Unión Europea está
estancando desde el 2019 el jefe de la
diplomacia europea
dijo que piensa que el año que viene por
fin se puede concretar
usted piensa que sí estoy hablando con
borrell en Buenos Aires cuando me visitó
hace dos semanas atrás
ese ese
acuerdo Unión Europea mercosur lo firmó
el gobierno que me presidió de Mauricio
macri y lo firmó el gobierno de
bolsonaro son es un
un acuerdo muy difícil de implementar
para economías como la de Brasil y la de
Argentina tendríamos que revisar algunas
cosas para poder implementarlas yo creo
que el vínculo entre la Unión Europea y
el mercosur debe ser un vínculo
privilegiado yo creo en eso creo en ese
acuerdo pero ese acuerdo tiene que tener
en cuenta las asimetrías que existen si
no se tienen en cuenta estas cosas vamos
a tener problemas
presidente macron hizo mucho hincapié en
la desatención de bolsonaro sobre el
cuidado de las amazonas y yo comparto su
mirada pero ahora está Lula Y esa mirada
desaprensiva sobre el Amazonas va a
desaparecer
pero lo que va a dejar al descubierto
que Francia no quiere terminar con los
subsidios agrícolas que suena de las
causas que también impiden el acuerdo
hay además un aspecto del acuerdo que
hay que atender muy especialmente que es
el acuerdo todo lo que Versa sobre la
industria automotriz
Argentina y Brasil son los dos
productores de automóviles para toda
América y la irrupción de la industria
europea Automotriz puede ser un gran
problema Para nuestras economías yo lo
que creo que debemos volver a sentarnos
ver estos dos problemas el problema
agrícola para parte de Europa el
problema Automotriz para para Brasil y
Argentina per de estos dos temas
ponerlos en un paraguas ver cómo podemos
avanzar con lo demás porque la vocación
existe sin ninguna duda Pero 2023 parece
difícil Yo creo que es difícil la
situación en Argentina hay mucho
inflación se habla tal vez de 100% al
final del año el gobierno está tomando
medidas pero parece que no alcanza para
frenar la infección es que tenemos
exactamente en el mismo problema que
tiene todo el mundo
nosotros para que la gente también se
sitúe hace 15 años que tenemos una
inflación de dos dígitos cuando yo
llegué al gobierno La inflación era del
54%
. la guerra ha hecho que esta inflación
se dispare como se disparó en todo el
mundo
multiplicamos por dos la inflación que
teníamos cuando en otros lugares del
mundo se multiplicó por 8 por 9 y hasta
por 10 Lo cierto es que es un problema
que estamos trabajando porque la
inflación definitivamente afecta a los
asalariados a los que viven un salario Y
lo que hacen es restarle valor al
salario de la gente estamos trabajando
mucho en eso con la dificultad de que
estamos en un mundo globalizado que el
precio de las energías ha subido que el
precio de los alimentos ha subido Y esta
es la combinación de ambas cosas generan
este problema pero eso también lo que
usted dijo puede ayudar a Argentina
alimentos algunas personas que dicen que
la guerra en Ucrania tal vez una buena
cosa para países como Argentina yo yo
efectivamente creo que para un país
productor de alimentos y un país que es
la segunda reserva de gas no
convencional del mundo es una gran
oportunidad que somos junto con junto
con chile y Bolivia tenemos el 66% de
las reservas de litio del mundo hay una
gran oportunidad Yo lamento que la
oportunidad sea como consecuencia de una
Guerra Quisiera que la oportunidad se
nos dé así en la guerra
nosotros vamos a tratar de ser parte
también de la solución de los problemas
del mundo queremos ser proveedores de
energía de Europa queremos ser
proveedores de alimentos de todo el
mundo pero eso eso es aumentos de
precios que se ven en todo el mundo
también repercuten en Argentina quiero
hablar un poco de la situación política
en Argentina hay tensiones entre usted
la vicepresidente Cristina kirchner esas
tensiones normalmente hay una Primaria
para elegir el candidato para la
elección de 2023 van a tener luego de
esas primarias miren nosotros lo que yo
yo siempre digo lo mismo frente a esta
pregunta primero las tensiones no son
tan importantes como las presentan la
prensa no son tan importantes
francamente no son tan importantes
tenemos miradas diferentes en algunas
cosas sí la tenemos es así ahora
lo que todos estamos seguros es hacer la
necesidad de seguir juntos para evitar
que el pasado vuelva a la Argentina el
pasado fue el que nos endeudó como nos
endeudó el pasado fue el que cerró
23.000 pequeñas y medianas empresas ese
pasado no queremos volver no queremos
volver y para eso tenemos que estar
Unidos
vamos a resolver las cosas como se
resuelven en democracia y seguramente
vamos a trabajar y hablar en su momento
con con todas las partes integrantes del
frente para buscar las mejores salidas
las mejores caminos
mi responsabilidad en este tiempo es
gobernar y resolver todos los problemas
que usted me está preguntando el
problema mío es la inflación el problema
mío es el deterioro de los salarios y
tengo que concentrarme en la solución de
esos problemas tenemos muy buenos datos
en la economía Argentina por ejemplo
por primera vez desde el año 2007 la
Argentina va a crecer su producto bruto
tres años consecutivamente
hemos creado un millón 300 mil puestos
de trabajo
tenemos
récord de exportaciones y
récord de inversiones en Argentina con
lo cual las perspectivas económicas son
buenas con el problema de la inflación
de lo que hablamos yo me tengo que
ocupar de eso resolver esos problemas y
cuando llegue el momento de la lección
lo resolveremos como lo resolvemos en
democracia usted quiere ser candidato yo
no pienso en eso yo la verdad
decoración crear un político
Mi mayor preocupación Es que la
Argentina de una vez por todas entra en
una senda de crecimiento y de mejor
distribución del ingreso esa Mi mayor
obsesión Yo sé que hemos hecho una
presidencia además que en términos de
calidad institucional ha sido intachable
muchas de las malas prácticas que en la
Argentina de los últimos años y décadas
se han visto desaparecieron durante
nuestra gestión y yo ahora yo estoy muy
orgulloso
y creo que ha dejado quiero dejar los
cimientos firmes para que en el futuro
no vuelvan a darse esas malas prácticas
y la decisión será cuando más o menos
cuando llegue el momento de las paso que
esto será mediados de año quiero hablar
del mundial de fútbol empieza en unos en
un par de días en Qatar existe una gran
polémica en Europa en torno a las
condiciones laborales de los
trabajadores extranjeros no
el ex director técnico de la selección
de Argentina Jorge San Pablo y dijo hace
poco la FIFA determinó jugar en un lugar
que no se debería haber jugar todo por
la plata todo un negocio Cuál es su
opinión sobre este tema
La verdad es que Bueno la verdad que la
definición de de Qatar como sede hizo
explotar el fifagate
Esta es la realidad ahora ya es un hecho
consumado tenemos que ir a jugar al
fútbol acatar y tenemos que ver de ganar
el campeonato mundial que es lo que
queremos los argentinos
todo lo demás si yo emitiera un juicio
sería un irresponsable siempre suelo
decir que como me siento muy libre digo
lo que pienso pero como soy responsable
pienso lo que digo entonces es un tema
delicado ese está claro que
hay un hay un gris en este mundial que
quedó evidenciado con el FIFA Gate pero
pero lo que debemos pensar ahora los
argentinos es en ver cómo ganamos con
Messi
el mundial Tenemos un gran equipo y un
gran técnico Sí vamos a hablar un
momento pero en la historia hubo un
mundial en Argentina
en 78 La dictadura militar Sí a la
Argentina ganó pero también hubo muchas
discusiones sobre el tema se debe
organizar un mundial en un país la
realidad es que el mundial en Argentina
fue resuelto antes La dictadura sobre
vino la dictadura y se jugó
los que fueron campeones en ese mundial
la verdad que dieron todo por salir
campeones
Pero bueno Siempre queda a esas
discusiones siempre existen no
la la mácula de una dictadura siempre
siempre existe pero creo que los que
jugaron y fueron al campo de juego y
representaron a la Argentina lo hicieron
dejando todo así todo de Sí y de hecho
el técnico de la selección argentina
Entonces era un hombre que era
reconocido por su distancia con la
dictadura no era precisamente un hombre
cercano a la Dictadura bueno Y entonces
ahora solo hablando de fútbol última
pregunta Quién va a ganar el mundial
Argentina con Messi o Francia con mbappé
Bueno yo que ganen mejor Pero yo mi
deseo que gane Argentina Definitivamente
creo que Messi lo merece creo que
tenemos un gran equipo también lo tiene
Francia hay muchos equipos Alemania
Brasil tiene un equipo impresionante va
a ser un mundial muy competitivo creo
muy competitivo donde Argentina creo que
llegan las mejores condiciones porque
tenemos un técnico que ha sabido Buscar
jugadores con hambre de Gloria y eso
creo que es el mayor potencial que
tenemos especialmente para Messi al
final Messi además lo merece porque es
un jugador extraordinario de una
humildad increíble y es un es un jugador
que nos llena nos llena los ojos nos
llena de alma cuando lo vimos jugar y
esta vez gracias a Dios Parece que que
Dios hizo justicia y le está empezando a
dar los triunfos que él merece en la
selección argentina Ojalá sea Ojalá se
dé Y sí última pregunta si llega
Argentina a la final se va a ir no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no hubiera ley por televisión
como casi todos los argentinos
Alberto Fernández Muchísimas gracias Y
muchísimas gracias a ustedes
[Música]